planus qu'une unité c'est de rester un
homme est de ne pas avoir honte et
d'être fier d'être un homme
[Applaudissements]
ils ont changé parce que ils vont
travailler au dehors comme on dit
maintenant petit opus comme et à la
pilule maintenant et qui leur permet de
baiser sans risque
eh bien on peut faire cocu sont mariés
comme on veut sans aucun sens aucun
inconvénient
[Musique]
pourquoi vous venez ici et de préférence
avec votre fils parce que c'est un
endroit masculin où on est en train mais
comme j'ai un fils un garçon bas pour
lui c'est une bonne chose parce que je
suis pas en contact avec toutes les
lesbiennes les [ __ ] et les [ __ ] du
mlf qui ne pensent qu'à toucher des
pensions alimentaires à des prestations
compensatoires
après avoir filé a pris les enfants en
otage par le biais des ayatollahs du
palais de justice
[Musique]
iajour est pas non plus devenir
défenseur des hommes ce soir mais on ne
sait plus comment les miens ne sait plus
par quel bout le prendre parce qu'elle
nous de vons trop vite
elle viole un tout petit peu brillé
[Musique]
pendant longtemps j'étais en accord avec
les féministes donc je m'écrase et je me
suis je me suis castrés gg réprimer mais
désire je me suis fait dominer par
conviction idéologique
j'en ai pas été très heureux et ça a pas
donné de très bons résultats
[Musique]
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas qu'en ce
moment avec la condition féminine
il ya certains jours on se demande si
les hommes existent encore et bien tout
autre avec un tout autre point de vue
celui d'eric zemmour journaliste au
figaro
[Musique]
il ya aussi ce que j'appelle les valeurs
c'est-à-dire les valeurs dominantes dans
la société qui sont adoptées par les
hommes sont toutes des valeurs
traditionnellement féminines
vous savez bien c'est la paix pas la
guerre le consensus pas l'autorité le la
précaution pas le risque etc
les jeunes hommes ont des mots et des
comportements de médine est très fleur
bleue
[Musique]